[Music]
action
thank you joe you're screaming my dad's
like huh
[Laughter]
g-o mama
[Applause]
i was on the phone with my dad trying to
explain to him that jill's mom's
thanking him for taking him to the park
and my dad's like huh and i have to keep
saying louder and louder and mandarin
by the way yeah cause he's so freaking
deaf but what was the phrasing of that
mama
the mama
taika hyoko go chi gong
but he said it like ten times no joke
well i think it was more than
wait because so much that like we all
remembered
like it was like a cd was on skit it was
loud at first
and i didn't think he'd get louder which
was nuts he was chill day mama
oh my god why are you speaking like a
mouse oh damn bar was crying at the end
of
does he know that his hearing's that bad
though does he know
well he knows because so he used to work
at uh commerce casino yeah
and then so he started getting
reprimanded because
people at like telling them to either
hit or like i want to do this with my
cards and you can't [ __ ] with people's
money at the casino
but he is [ __ ] people's money because
he's not hearing the commands
and then he got reprimanded a couple
times and then i think he was like oh
[ __ ] that's like two strikes in like a
month he goes
i'm about to get fired i quit i think he
knows that he just can't hear [ __ ]
usually like people have like hand
signals too right
yeah but some black jacks sometimes like
yeah like he also deals poker too so
they don't
like you have to talk and stuff and yeah
yeah he's just
he i think he knew he was on the verge
wow he just needs to get those [ __ ]
large horns
those old hearing aids and then when he
picks up the phone he just throws the
phone in there
anyway this story seen one of those this
story totally has nothing to do with
anything in this
realm of conversation but that was
really funny
well anyway we're talking about tana
here tana
montana monjo mojo who's that
mojo i know that's how she says it in
her videos i never know how to say her
last name i thought it was like mongoo
kind of mongoo what did she do that's
jake that's jake paul's wife
not anymore so we've talked about her
plenty on the show
she's a youtuber she tends to make
headlines a lot because
controversial a lot to be very
controversial she looks like a porn star
and now she's like 18 news because of
the fact that she started this
this little she's 18
no she's 22. what no she started when
she was 16 like a few years ago really
she's 20 22 according to this article
what what kind of content she always
talked about being a minor
she's 22 still she's still the oldest
[ __ ] for 22. you know maybe
uh maybe time she looks pretty fast for
me yeah she's 22 now i'm so old she's
22.
okay what is she like a vlogger or like
she's a vlogger gamer or
also is famous for being um that one
actress's
ex-girlfriend bella thorne bella thorne
and also for
paul anyway the point is she tweeted
that she didn't have a tv show
she tweeted i don't even know who bella
thorne is it's okay if you send me proof
you voted for biden i'll send you a nude
for free
and then she puts her only booty for
biden isn't that exactly what
uh uh the carly the fire girl did
who oh never mind the fire the the
remember the fires in australia the girl
was sounding out [ __ ] pig
yeah yeah oh that's yeah that is
different
because here is an actual
like what she is doing is an electoral
crime oh really a crime a u.s
electoral you can't do that a federal
crime yeah
yeah so you can't buy votes like she's
pretty much like
soliciting votes bribing votes yeah
bribing for votes
it's called vote buying i see and it's
an electoral crime
and so people like a lot of people
believe that she
broke the law so the fbi are gonna
freaking because it's federal too right
yeah so i as of yet i don't know if she
has faced any actual
legal repercussions what happened she
has news it was a [ __ ] video from no
makeup
oh so here's a video where
she talks about how like her fans
center stuff oh how come she didn't
dress the other way
the other way that's a filter that's the
filter we talked about
baby face look like a baby because that
looks like the white chicks filter
you know from the movie yeah yeah oh she
does she looks like modern ways
[Laughter]
here's the video uncensored messages are
officially broken and the point has been
made i got tens of thousands of messages
of people telling me that they willingly
voted for joe biden
and it's the best thing ever you don't
need my ass to make you
go vote so go vote because you want to
see a change in this country just like
me and thank you to everybody
who joined me today booty for biting
so they just got a picture of her
[ __ ] ass that's it uh
well i don't know what they got but
apparently they got nudes and then she
also posted this on instagram that's
probably what they got
well you want to see the other side do
you want to see yeah i guess it's like
the other side
can we see the nudes though yeah i
didn't pay for this i don't know i bet
you was on reddit somewhere did you just
get on reddit
david i know your horny ass will find it
okay i gotta see proof here we go
anyway so that's what she's she's in the
news about
for whatever these days for that reason
but how come no one's talking about joe
jorgensen
who's that is the libertarian candidate
the third option because i want a third
option i want a third option but then no
one actually votes for the third office
oh
we do have a third one the libertarian
yeah
george organ or you can go green party
but i forget who their candidate is mr
green
no so is the green party all about like
climate stuff because that's what that
sounds
like maybe i don't know i don't really
know i thought it was about the money
beer
so what's going to happen to tana
mangalo what's your name is she going to
go to jail
town of mongolia what's up napoleon
anyway i do not know what the actual
repercussions of this are is just a lot
of people are speculating the fact that
she
technically did break the law what is it
called uh it's called vote
vote you look in what is the punishment
for vote by
u.s marshals will break into your house
descend by helicopter
extra action read all about it talk
about go
manga that's pretty crazy well you see
you broke the navy seals will you much
one to five years imprisonment
damn old ass [ __ ] ham radio
i wonder if she'll be able to vlog in
prison
i'll be pretty sick prison vloggers i
follow a fitness dude
that has a ton of content from prison
how like he's doing like dips and
push-ups and stuff prison workouts
i think he probably look at himself in
his booty hole and he's
continuing his i don't know his
influence
so he has a prison tick tock yeah he
like he'll put two of his like
he's like oh uh i just you know i got
promoted from class one prison or
something
where like i share a cell now i'm in
like the the general population where
it's class three like we're all about to
get out
and he's like doing push-ups between two
beds and stuff it's like an orange is a
new black that
these two girls found the phone and they
started a youtube channel and they went
viral this was sponsored
it's a lot easier to get a phone than
people think yeah a friend told me that
it's you just pay off a guard and the
guard will bring so
it doesn't have to be in your ass no it
doesn't and they're pretty because
smartphones are getting pretty
especially if you're getting affiliated
apparently they'll they got the hookup
so they'll find somebody to give you
something did you see that one a tick
tock where a whole bunch of prisoners
did where
it was that one trend where like people
go in yeah
and then they go out and the prisoners
did it yeah there were prisoners doing
that
pretty funny and they all got beat up
after doing it huh
was it worth it yeah it was [ __ ]
we went viral cuz
what if everyone wants to be a youtube
star now and it doesn't even matter like
like there's no you can't be too cool
anymore
it's about tick tock people are trying
to be tick-tock it's a lot easier
because even dog face
[ __ ] forgot a truck
full of juice i know you stand so crazy
man why's his videos made me feel so
good
it does it just made me feel ethereal
dude yeah it does make you feel real
good
it makes me feel like i'm just relaxing
today tick-tock is crazy though
something about a cholo on a skateboard
and just
his feather tattoo is sick you're so
chill
so tana here she is saying that that
whole post and that whole like booty for
biting campaign was sarcastic and that
obviously she
did not break any laws and
and she ended up tweeting oh because a
lot of people were speculating that the
rep repercussions yeah the grim
repercussions
that uh because she ended up losing her
verification
badge on youtube that's serious on
youtube yeah she lost
the verification badge on youtube yeah i
got it and i went away
you don't have one you have one no i
have no idea you probably have you
probably have one fine never even seen
it
she ended up losing that verification
badge so people are saying like
maybe she lost the badge because she's
because of this right and then she ended
up tweeting
it wasn't i only received people oh
because we were saying that
this is an electoral crime and then she
says it wasn't i only received people
telling me
what they wanted to do you don't need my
ass to tell you who to vote for
i lost youtube verification because i
accidentally [ __ ] up uploading in the
back end of my account it's back now
[ __ ] the news lol
they need to get her on judge judy or
something why is judy
i don't know just if she's always
getting canceled like every month
like she's one of those people that just
like leave her alone relevant by
by getting cancelled cancel oh she likes
it yeah
it's that kind of stuff you're having
her name in the drama
channels yeah because it wasn't like as
far as i remember she ended up becoming
a popular youtube
youtuber because her videos were like
story
story times yeah it's like major drama
that had happened in her life
yeah she had like uber stories yeah all
these uber driver stories
yeah so i don't know that's that's
tana's
thing here it's tana panama little
say it properly please say it right now
you need a stroke what's your name
are you guys voting this year are you
guys going i think we passed our time to
vote dude
no we didn't how come everybody going
like i voted
california right there in those little
ballot boxes dude yeah we didn't
i didn't register so [ __ ] it kanye 2020
[ __ ]
you have up until in the state of
california up until november third
to uh go up i got a [ __ ] vote to
register for vote
joe siff i ain't gonna [ __ ] vote
that's his right as a [ __ ]
american it is it is his right to do
whatever he wants
yep we just got our ballots in the mail
[Music]
same
[Music]
you